[Música]
Hola soy Marina sardina y les doy la
bienvenida a Expreso de oriente El
magazine quincenal de France 24 en el
que les acercamos las historias de medio
oriente América Latina Esto es lo que
veremos en nuestro programa de hoy en
Egipto los esfuerzos del gobierno para
silenciar las constantes violaciones a
los Derechos Humanos que se suceden en
el país contra los activistas no han
tenido éxito y durante la Cumbre mundial
del clima la co-27 las miradas
estuvieron no solo puestas en los
líderes mundiales sino también en los
presos políticos del régimen y en Irán
se cumplen dos meses del mayor estallido
social en años las protestas que
comenzaron por la muerte de Max samini
han escalado a más de 140 localidades y
los reclamos son también contra el
régimen de la República islámica cuya
brutal represión deja cientos de muertos
y miles de detenidos
y Qatar es la sede del mundial de fútbol
2022 una competición empañada por las
muertes de miles de trabajadores
migrantes el emirato cataris escuda en
su forma tradicional de contratación
laboral el sistema cafala mientras las
ongs denuncian violaciones de los
Derechos Humanos
iniciamos en Egipto porque el régimen
egipcio de fatal sí sí no ha conseguido
su propósito de lavar su imagen con la
Cumbre mundial del clima con 27 y ha
pasado de querer mostrarse como el
escaparate para los derechos de sus
ciudadanos a una muestra más de la
represión que sufren los críticos del
régimen como el abogado y activista por
los Derechos Humanos a la app de fatá
quien ha pasado el mayor parte de sus
últimos nueve años privados de libertad
lo cuenta desde el Cairo nuestra
corresponsal Nuria tesón
será recordada como la Cumbre de los
Derechos Humanos dicen los activistas
que no puede haber justicia climática si
no hay un respeto a los derechos y
libertades de las personas y lo
reivindican en Egipto un país que tiene
60.000 prisioneros políticos en nombre
de uno de ellos a la adver fatal ha
estado resonando consistentemente en los
actos de esta Cumbre del clima ala Lleva
más de 8 años en la cárcel Pero además
en abril empezó una huelga de hambre
coincidiendo con el inicio de la Cumbre
del clima también dejó de beber agua a
su hermana pequeña sanaseiff habló
durante esta Cumbre siendo además
implicada por un parlamentario que se
encontraba en la sala en ese momento y
defendió que su hermano no está
encerrado en las cárceles egipcias por
un post en Facebook en el que
supuestamente dijo María a Egipto sino
por darnos la esperanza de que pueda
haber un lugar mejor que es precisamente
lo que están demandando aquellos que
participan estos días en la competi y
siete por eso hoy la asamblea de la
gente ha coreado el nombre de alá y ha
pedido la libertad de este activista y
la de todos los activistas y prisioneros
políticos que se encuentran en las
cárceles egipcias para Egipto era una
oportunidad de oro poder cordearse con
líderes internacionales y hacer un
completo lavado de imagen ante el mundo
durante esta Cumbre del clima pero esa
campaña de relaciones públicas se ha
vuelto en su contra y ha terminado
siendo un escaparate de como vulnera
consistentemente los Derechos Humanos
dentro del país y como los gobiernos
europeos y estadounidenses siguen
haciendo negocios con Egipto sin que les
importe lo más mínimo lo que está
ocurriendo con los Derechos Humanos algo
que los activistas llevan años pidiendo
que cambie que simplemente en medidas
reales para frenar esas vulneraciones de
Derechos Humanos por eso es tan
importante esta Cumbre y por eso los
activistas egipcios y organizaciones no
gubernamentales como human right watch
denuncian y piden que se mantengan muy
atentos para ver lo que ocurre una vez
que se acabe esta Cumbre porque el temor
de todos es que una vez que los focos se
alejen la represión vuelva aún con más
virulencia a Egipto
la brutal represión de las autoridades
iraníes no ha logrado acallar las
protestas que se suceden en Irán Desde
hace dos meses tras el asesinato de la
joven maxa mini procedente del kurdistán
iraní tras ser detenida por la policía
de la moral un estallido sin precedentes
liderado por la juventud iraní pero cuyo
reclamo se extendieron con proclamas
contra el régimen de la república
islámica que continúa con las
detenciones masivas y el intento de
silenciar a los manifestantes en las
calles con disparos y ejecuciones de los
arrestados podrán las protestas traer un
cambio real en Irán lo hablamos para
responder a estas preguntas tenemos con
nosotros a Catalina Gómez Ángel ella es
corresponsal de France 24 en Teherán
Catalina bienvenida a Expreso de oriente
cuéntanos hasta cuándo puede el régimen
islámico usar la fuerza para silenciar a
los manifestantes y también se pueden
estas protestas traer medidas y cambios
reales en medio de esta violenta
disuasión
Marina para empezar hay cambios
lo que han logrado las mujeres y los
jóvenes en
cada semanas por ejemplo se puede
vivenciar en la calle no lo es todo Es
simplemente la punta del iceberg pero el
velo en este país significa muchísimas
cosas porque la República islámica y
toda la represión contra las mujeres se
quiso fundar bajo esta imposición del
vestir islámico que ellos aseguraban que
tenía que ser obligatorio para todas las
mujeres y lo que hemos visto durante
estos dos meses es que las mujeres no
todas parte y las que
más Valientes de cierta manera Porque da
mucho miedo se han quitado
por las calles de Teherán en muchos
sectores en los más tradicionales
también se ve esto y esto ya es un gran
logro para las mujeres que logran como
las policías las policías los incluso
los milicianos miran hacia otro lado van
a seguir usando la violencia
posiblemente
y posiblemente la van a usar con más
intensidad de las próximas semanas en la
medida que la represión sigue siendo
mayor y las protestas siguen
incrementándose hemos visto como han
aumentado otra vez en estos dos días no
solamente reclamando la muerte de Maxi
sino aquellos que murieron o fueron
asesinados en los 2019 en el mes de
noviembre y hemos visto con la
intensidad y la violencia con la que han
vuelto a responder las autoridades
Catalina precisamente algunos analistas
hablan de que esta es una de las mayores
revoluciones feministas en el mundo
precisamente por la represión a la que
se enfrentan Estas mujeres cuando salen
a la calle a protestar cuéntanos Qué
representa este grito que sea
popularizado de mujer vida y Libertad
lo que ha logrado las mujeres y
especialmente las mujeres jóvenes porque
esto Realmente está liderado por ellas
ha sido
congregar e Irán en esas protestas en
esa
desafección con el régimen en esa rabia
que tienen pero alrededor de los
derechos y de la opresión a la que en
estado sometidas las mujeres Entonces
han sido ellas las que a través de ese
grito de mujer
vida y Libertad yendo hacia la calle
quitándose ese velo gritando por los
derechos de ellas y por esa opresión Y
esa represión a la que he sido sometidas
durante estas 43 años las que han
logrado realmente impulsar y motivar a
que a otras personas y especialmente de
los jóvenes hombres las acompañen en
esta lucha hay que decir la verdad no
todo el país se siente motivado por esos
eslogan
las mujeres muchos de ellos se sienten
más motivados por ese eslogan de muerte
al dictador o la o el cambio de
régimen pero son las mujeres las que con
esa primera impulsar en estas protestas
que tal vez han cambiado al país como
nunca había sucedido en estos 43 años
precisamente Catalina también es esta
obligatoriedad del velo lo que sacó a
las calles a estas mujeres pero hay algo
más profundo detrás de este estallido
algo contra el régimen que venía pasando
y que se venía sucediendo en Irán para
que esta rabia esté todavía en las
calles dos meses después de del
asesinato de Max aminy
es lo que sucedió con maxamín Es bien
interesante porque nunca se sabe cuál va
a ser esa
ese suceso que realmente marque un antes
y un después en el país no es la primera
muerte que sucede no la primera mujer
que es abusada por la policía de la
moral Pero lo que marcha representa es
la indignación que ya venía sus
sentimientos desde hace muchísimos meses
porque desde que llegó a la presidencia
Ibrahim Racing ha venido presionando y
presionando y presionando a la sociedad
especialmente a las mujeres con esa
policía moral o el gaster chat que
estaba en la calle y es que ya no te
cogían por por no llevar el pelo te
cogían por el llevarlo aquí por aquí por
llevar la camisa incluso correctamente
no no había realmente una norma por la
cual se estableciera estuviera
reprimiendo
que la población cada vez es más
consciente de la corrupción de los
abusos del régimen del y también el
mismo sistema cerró los espacios
políticos donde la gente podía protestar
antes bien o mal existía una especie de
democracia dentro de la estructura de la
república islámica donde se podía elegir
a uno más moderado más reformista o más
conservador gente tenía su oportunidad Y
eso se perdió desde que ellos realmente
hicieron todos los movimientos para
poner a ibra Y sí como presidente de la
república hace un año un clérigo radical
y así igual está el parlamento con un
parlamento más radical de toda la
historia de la República islámica
entonces dentro del mismo sistema no hay
críticas no hay diálogo no hay
diferentes ideas y obviamente todo esto
juega para crear Esa esa circunstancias
que nos tienen en este momento donde
estamos Muchísimas gracias Catalina y
Seguiremos muy pendientes de lo que está
sucediendo en Irán
miles de trabajadores en su mayoría
migrantes han fallecido durante la
construcción de los edificios y estadios
para el mundial de Qatar 2022 otros
denuncian impagos y las condiciones
infrahumanas a las que han estado
viviendo Y sometidos esta es la sombra
que empaña la mayor competición
futbolística del mundo activistas por
los Derechos Humanos vienen denunciando
que el Mega evento deportivo está
manchado de sangre veamos el siguiente
informe que preparó un equipo de France
24 en Qatar
estos rascacielos están a la altura de
las ambiciones desmedidas de Qatar pero
quienes construyeron las torres de doha
jamás tendrán los medios para vivir en
ellas son trabajadores que viven lejos
del centro de la ciudad al final de
estas autopistas para llegar un
trabajador keniano nos guía aceptó dar
su testimonio a condición de permanecer
anónimo Afirma haberle pagado 1500
dólares a una agencia de reclutamiento
keniana por su visa y su pasaje de avión
pero solo después de haber llegado al
país en 2020
Cuál era la empresa catari que lo había
contratado
cuando llegué ese mismo día empecé a
trabajar
al principio hacíamos cemento para los
edificios
en fin un trabajo de construcción
durante el verano hace mucho calor aquí
la temperatura a veces supera los 50
grados no es fácil cuando trabajamos
afuera el calor nos golpea uno tiene la
sensación de que se va a morir al igual
que la mayoría de los trabajadores
extranjeros Ibrahim vive en un
alojamiento concedido por su empleador a
decenas de kilómetros del centro de la
ciudad los periodistas tienen prohibido
el acceso a estos complejos pero
desesperados por sus condiciones de vida
Ibrahim y sus compañeros de habitación
corrieron el riesgo de dejarnos entrar
con una cámara Esta es nuestra
habitación
miren
aparte del alojamiento insalubre estos
trabajadores afirman no haber recibido
su salario en meses ha pasado casi un
año y no soy solo yo todos mis amigos
también Tratamos de hablar con el
empleador pero amenazó con Llamar a la
policía algunos quieren volver a su país
otros quieren cambiar de
empresas pero el empleador confiscó
nuestros pasaportes que podemos hacer
esto es esclavitud es como una prisión
un nuevo en forma de la red Siria para
los Derechos Humanos señala que el
régimen de vallar al azad ha liberado A
menos del 6% de los prisioneros
políticos detenidos en los más de 10
años de guerra civil en la nación árabe
según la organización de Derechos
Humanos más de 136.000 personas siguen
empresas en precarias condiciones en
comunicadas de sus familias muchos de
los detenidos fueron presos durante la
participación
masivas protestas anti gubernamentales
de 2011 que derivaron en el conflicto
que todavía se perpetúa en algunas
regiones sirias
llegamos así al final de esta edición de
Expreso de oriente Muchas gracias por
acompañarlos y los invito a enviar sus
comentarios a las redes sociales que
aparecen en sus pantallas y a seguir con
toda la información en nuestra página
web France 24.com
[Música]